hi vegas
first up madelina wines these wines were
created for women who are looking to
make their mark on the world just like
madeleine ribolli the wine's namesake
did herself
a woman who was way before her time
made elena is credited with opening one
of the first winery tasting rooms in
california back in 1947
because she knew customers would buy
more if they just had the chance to
taste the wines and boy was she correct
and i can personally tell you it worked
with seven amazing veritas packaged in
gorgeous new rose gold bottles there is
something for everyone two staples i
feel you can't go wrong with is their
cabernet or light crisp chardonnay which
pairs perfect with fish
salads or a charcuterie board with
spring just around the corner
madelina rabouli turns 100 years old
this december so go to madeleine
wines.com to find a retailer near you
now did you know that boob sweat yes
boob sweat is a very real common problem
and 82 percent of us women experience it
including me but no worries thanks to
dawn hunter's smoothie bra liners we now
have a solution for those hot vegas
nights smoothies are absorbent and
disposable bra liners that are made from
flexible baby soft layers that absorb
moisture and trap it deep inside leaving
your skin dry and bra fresh
smoothies provide all-day protection
preserve your lingerie reduce rashes
which was my problem
and prevent embarrassing visible wetness
be drier when you perspire with smoothie
bra liners
boxes are just under twenty dollars and
trial liners under six bucks so go to
swoopy.com
next the mira ball sisters from
caterpillars to butterflies is a newly
released book by rainelda a calderon
written in spanish and english and is a
book that is perfect for kids ages eight
to twelve
born in a small town in the dominican
republic the mirabal sisters lived at a
time when the country was under the
merciless rule of a dictatorship
these beloved sisters were called los
mariposas the butterflies by their
people and they had a butterfly effect
on their country by standing up to
trujillo
readers will be inspired by the story of
bravery and fearlessness in the face of
darkness it is truly a timeless story
honoring these heroic hispanic women to
get a copy go to raycc tense dot com
and lastly baggalini stands for smart
stylish on the go living the brand was
founded in 1995 and all bags are
designed to give women the organization
confidence and comfort to do it all
the brand was started by two
entrepreneurial female founders that
were two global travelers and leveraged
their insights from around the world to
create functional stylish bags to
enhance the lives of modern women
the soho duffel is the perfect carry-on
with a luggage handle sleeve and padded
laptop sleeve making this the perfect
bag for any flight
so whether it be a trip around the block
or around the globe they have a style
just for you at baggalini.com
so thank you to all these amazing women
who believed in their dreams and visions
that we now get to benefit from in our
daily lives go to donscorner.com for
more information and i will see you next
month